go on my channel
there's a chief of police where we live
i love them but then there's a sheriff
who
is a [ __ ] idiot he really is i don't
give a [ __ ] about he's an idiot
[ __ ] he's an egomaniac he's a [ __ ]
it not brevard county or yeah brevard
county sheriff he's whacked man he's
he's so about himself he's such a he's
his head
through that [ __ ] door yeah he comes
up with the wheel of [ __ ]
fugitive yeah he comes up with [ __ ]
fishing for justice with wayne ivy and
[ __ ] they go
and these people you know what the
people [ __ ] did violation of
probation bad check writing
so they put you on tv to really make you
look like a jerk off
is that really necessary and then you
get hardcore oh but he's a criminal
oh how many you know they did a study
did you know
the average person breaks the law three
times a day
hmm i'm not surprised i did it come
walking across the street yeah
jaywalking
so my point is at what point
are we part of the community because see
cops should belong
i'm like i said i support good cops
police reform and prison reform are my
specialty in police reforms
cops should be part of your community
right and if i have a kid that's so
[ __ ] up and they need larry's help all
this help
it's i don't give a [ __ ] if you go in
that house and you find [ __ ] coke or
pills or whatever
don't arrest them i didn't call you to
arrest my kid
i called you to help my kid oh but
he's breaking the law or or that's the
only way no it's not
we could try a lot better ways than what
you just said
give a record yeah it's a the law thing
situ it's become
to like now in the country it's almost
just like this mentality of
us versus them and i talk about that
every day then
once again you gotta break down that us
against them mentality yeah
imagine i was thinking about it i was
like imagine if we didn't have
cops we didn't have law enforcement what
would what would you do
well you would want to have as many
friends as possible
and you would want to have the weak weak
people would obviously want to become
friends with stronger people
and you would want to be able to be
protected you would want to feel you
have to have that sense of
of security or protection i'm just like
in a hypothetical world where yeah but
they had that
but they had that think of roman times
they had the king and he had his men
and they enforced whatever they wanted
because they were the strong or whatever
on the weak or whatever and even back in
the old days the united states in the
1700s and they had
they had a guy sheriffs in their 1800s
and stuff that would
yeah and they were usually criminals of
drugs so just the fastest guy with the
gun
right you know whatever how it worked
but what has happened
is they've gotten so much power
cops now he's such
a good politician as a sheriff and i
give him that
you know but he he only [ __ ] talks to
the people you know the old people he
scares them and all right right he could
never get to you
fear-mongering he can't get to a guy
like you is an independent thinker
who looks through him or or ryan or
people young
they look at them like who the [ __ ] are
you you know i know they tell me in my
class
right right right [ __ ] that guy's the
biggest dick i listen i know the guy
and he he doesn't want to help the jail
you know what he did for years in the
jail i don't know if they still do it
they didn't give women tampons really
how would you like to have a daughter or
your wife or a girl or anybody
and she's on a period and they
and they don't give them something to
help themselves i i i i
it blows my mind away how you can go
home
at night and say oh i did a great job
barbaric man it's barbara there's
not designed to help anybody it's not
none you know what his you know what his
line is
i want my jail to be the toughest jail
and
that's not what [ __ ] it's for it
should be for rehabilitation
right well yeah and they and and to hold
violent people
jails we [ __ ] it up and going out
there in the public and just saying we
need to be tough we need to get the
criminals off the spruce street and
branding them
branding them as these criminals to the
public it just makes people
especially older people who are who are
more vulnerable
to the media or to advertising or
whatever who have less
lesser [ __ ] detectors than we do oh
my god yeah
everybody talks about young people right
i love young people yeah i think you
guys are [ __ ] smarter
i think you guys are more informed i
think you have greater views than we
ever did
and i'm happy about the way it's going
with the young people
because i'm only here to give you my
experience whether it's whatever
i i help young people because there's
one thing you can't
you're smarter than me you got you you
know how to do a lot of things
yeah i know that's a good iq yeah but
it's not that
my point is i have experience in a place
you don't want to go
right i have experience because i i went
through life
i often tell young people i say you're
30. ryan's 20.
you're not smarter than him but you have
more experience than him so you
are and now you get a guy who's 40 years
old he's been in your business whatever
tv business
you say well that's not smart but he's
got more experience than me
so you're going to listen older people
got to know that you know most
older people let me tell you a great
story about young people people
i'm on i was on a board with the
department of justice
up in new york uh washington dc and at
the time i think i had a blackberry or
whatever it was
and i'm new but i'm working with kids a
lot so i
know a lot about young people kids i say
young people you're 20 years old
whatever
so we're at a big big conference room
and one of the people up there some of
these kids we got to give up on
what i stand up now i can get pretty you
know i stand up
i take my phone i slam it on the desk
everybody looks oh [ __ ] this guy's crazy
or whatever
i go who in this room can program their
phone quicker than their 16 year old kid
they all were silent i said you know
what larry
gets the phone opens the book hits
button one
opens the book hits i get there do you
know what my daughter does
she takes the phone starts playing with
it reboots it plays with it reboots it
plays with it reboots it here daddy it's
done
she did it quicker than me what does
that show us
oh look i said they learned differently
than us and sometimes it's better than
us
and when we as adults don't listen
and just think it's our way to [ __ ]
highway
we're wrong and until we get out of that
[ __ ] space
will never better this country or better
to young people and i'm big on that
i love working with my uh the reason and
i believe this my channel has grown so
quickly
and we were the fastest growing channel
on youtube the reason
is because i have experience with my
partner
uh my manager peter genius
then i got my son who's 30 31
and i got darian who's 20
or 21 i listen to them
now are they always right no and i make
my decisions from there
uh for other reasons for experience
reasons or business reasons or whatever
it is but i listen to them when they say
to me like i remember you know
i started my youtube channel with an
iphone really with a [ __ ] iphone
nothing else literally nothing else
then i bought a 30 dollar [ __ ] tripod
and a [ __ ] thing
that's all i started with you filming
the videos on your phone in my bed not
not now
uh i do i actually sometimes do three
four camera shoots or whatever and i use
them still
i've done this with mega tv companies
iphones you know
this is the 11 pro max because they're
the front cameras so yeah
the front camera is amazing that's why i
did it but my so
darry and my son i have flew them in we
had a meeting and all that kind of stuff
and they said to me sit down i still had
the iphone
and i don't know six months ago eight
months or whatever it was they go
my son says pop darren goes loud he goes
gotta get better cameras and to this day
i look at the same video i can't pick it
out
but i guarantee you could and i
guarantee ryan could
that's funny guarantee it you guys are
in a good space because of your ages
and you just got to follow that you know
get your get your
older guy maybe or whatever but you guys
are in a good space because you know
what
your audience first once you know who
you order my audience is young
so but i didn't notice it i still don't
but we got good cameras now i got you
know the cameras like all the [ __ ]
that we all need but you know they're on
me and i got another one here and then
i'll put this one another
sound we're still upgrading we're always
doing little things
i don't even know it that's great man
but i listened to them yeah you trying
to
you surrounded yourself with smart
people that know what they're doing i'm
sorry and
and with the age yeah you know that's
why i'm very happy the way this
country's going
people aren't oh it's [ __ ] going
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong with it
tell me
because they are independent thinkers
and they don't want war and they want
legalized drugs
okay why not i often when when they
start that [ __ ]
i know i love this well it's going to be
anarchy in the streets oh really go to
look at switzerland go look in norway
they were all [ __ ] legalized
everything
right recidivism went down up you know
no lower citizen lower crime rates
lower addiction rates saving money tell
me why
it's big money is fighting it prison
system the private prison system
they're fighting it [ __ ] people law
enforcement you know why they fight it
because they get money for it right they
get
[ __ ] tons of money to [ __ ] have
drug tests for us and tank [ __ ] tasks
well
it's [ __ ] that's military in our
streets
law enforcement should be andy [ __ ]
griffin what do you think you know andy
griffin remember
mayberry [ __ ] rfd with [ __ ] barney
you're too young
yeah i missed out on a lot of that stuff
[Laughter]